you can't just say this is the way it is
therefore it ought to be that way
gotta have good reason so I claim well
we do have good reasons democracies are
better than autocracies free markets are
better than top-down tyrannical
you know economic systems communist
systems and so on there's certain things
we know work you can measure hi I'm Zack
why similar for reason TV I'm here with
Michael Shermer author editor of skeptic
magazine monthly columnist at Scientific
American and professor at Chapman
University his latest book is the moral
arc how science and reason lead humanity
towards truth justice and freedom
Michael thank you very much for joining
oh you're welcome the book builds in
many ways on the works of writers like
Steven Pinker in that it tries to
demonstrate that the world's becoming
not only less violent and in many ways
more prosperous but actually more moral
and you tie that growth in morality or
that moral evolution to an embrace of
reason and science but before we get too
deeply into that I just want to define
terms what is morality well here we're
talking about how people treat one
another there's no moral questions if
you're alone in a desert island by
yourself and so I'm building on the idea
of the the survival and flourishing of
sentient beings so things that lead to
more of that or moral things that lead
to less that are not moral or immoral I
use that because I'm taking a biological
approach so in addition to Pinker of Sam
Harris's moral landscape I'm building on
that as well Sam starts with just a
philosophical starting point of the
well-being of conscious creatures is how
he phrases it but but why there why
start there I claim that evolution has
endowed us with a desire to survive and
flourish by survival I mean you know
just just being able to be alive and
flourishing having enough to eat a place
to sleep you know social network if
you're a social species and so forth
just the basics of life and what I'm
claiming is that we've gotten better at
doing that especially over the last
several centuries
considering more and more people as
worthy of being in our moral community
as people we whose survival and
flourishing we care about to the point
now that we even care about animals
other other sentient beings described
briefly what you mean by sentience and
why you choose that as your baseline for
morality yes by sentience I mean the
ability to feel sense emote suffer and
so on so and this is building on the
work of Jeremy Bentham who said about
animals
it isn't that can they think and they
talk and they make tools those kinds of
things that we've always talked about
distinguishing ourselves from other
animals but can they feel can they
suffer and that's a deeper part of the
brain whether you can have language or
tool use or higher forms of cognition in
the in the cerebral cortex you know that
is vouchsafed really pretty much to us
and maybe one or two other species if
you count chimps or something like that
or dolphins but when I'm talking about
what Bentham was talking about is a much
deeper evolutionary parts of the brain
the limbic system the amygdala areas
hippocampus areas that are old
evolutionarily ancient that have to do
with just the basics of survival
flourishing suffering pain when we talk
about the modern liberal tradition it's
often been defined at the human level
and you know the idea of humanism does
this conflict with that at all do you
think that it undermines idea that only
humans have rights I know it doesn't
conflict at all I'm just saying let's
just go even further now I will admit we
haven't even accomplished that yet as
much progress as we made you only have
to tune in The Daily News to see that
there's still violations of human rights
clearly not all humans are in the moral
sphere yet but in the Western liberal
tradition in Western democracies at
least in principle every single human
being should be a member of the moral
community and now with the animal rights
movement all the great apes pretty much
all primates marine mammals any any
sentient being capable of suffering and
feeling which is a lot of species should
be incorporated that if not in a
practice at least in principle and we
should work toward that and you grapple
with the question that philosophers
and scientists of dealt with for ages
which is is morality innate or do we
learn it from our parents priests
community or something in between what
is the scientific evidence point to
along that spectrum now the oven is
pretty strong that it's it's mixed of
course your environment makes a big
difference but just in terms of
evolutionary perspective we evolved a
capacity to care about other sentient
beings to also be concerned about them
or worried about them or aggressive
toward them and that so we have this
dual nature of being both amicable and
cooperative and altruistic to our fellow
in-group members but being xenophobic
aggressive violent against out group
members and and and there's perfectly
good reasons why that would be as Jared
Diamond likes to say about the
indigenous peoples he encounters in
Papua New Guinea if you encounter a
complete stranger out on a path it would
be suicide to just stick your hand out
and say you know a welcome neighbor like
we do in the West because you good
chance you'd be killed so it's good to
be cautious it's good to be xenophobic
in terms of our evolutionary perspective
now what's happened is is that we've
developed civil societies in which the
rule of law and other mechanisms make it
more trustworthy that it's okay to shake
total strangers hands what we've done by
expanding the moral sphere is to say
let's keep those negative aspects of our
nature in check xenophobia
aggressiveness violence has sort of
thing and try to try to push the better
angels as Pinker likes to say we have
inner demons and better angels and
what's been happening for the last
several centuries is that the better
angels are winning out over the inner
demons but they're they're really there
they're part of our nature for good
reason not just some cultural thing and
so while culture tweaks your Moral
Sentiments that the basics of it are
inside the sense of revenge and justice
and desire for equality and equal
treatment those things are part of our
nature and you make the case that the
key to expanding or a key component of
expanding that moral sphere has been
the existence of empathy or imagining
the perspective of others and but this
is an evolved trait how did that evolve
and why is it so important to the moral
arc empathy it's not a foolproof thing
you can empathize with your in-group
against other people so that they can it
can cut both ways but what I'm talking
about here is just the capacity to to
put yourself in somebody else's shoes is
an 8 it's definitely there Adam Smith
talked about it in his first book that
that morality is based on the fact that
we're able to do this and not not just
mind read where I can imagine what
you're thinking but actually feel if
you're suffering I can feel your
suffering that that's the basis of
morality now the reason for that is
because we're a social primate species
and so we have to get along with the
other members of our group we have to
kind of know what they're thinking and
feeling in order to anticipate their
actions in order to get them to
cooperate with us we have to cooperate
with them you can't just pretend to be a
nice person because if you're faking and
you're just manipulating using people
like a psychopath would to get something
other people will see that they'll - you
can tell the tells the cues that
somebody's pretending so it's real
morality and I'd not pretend it's not a
calculation evolutions done the
calculating for us we actually feel
emotions proxies to drive behavior so
it's better to actually feel empathy
empathy for somebody else rather than to
pretend it in the book you talk a lot
about individual rights and you say that
actually scientifically speaking it
makes sense to define rights at an
individual level rather than a
collective level what's the scientific
case for individual rights I would call
that natural law that is nature has
endowed us individually to care about
our own well-being and that of our
immediate kin in kind and beyond that no
so I'm not a group selection estai don't
think that evolution is based on group
selection I think it is based on the
individual organism setting aside ants
and social insects or something like
that
but just taking primates for example we
it's based on whether you personally can
suffer and then from there you can just
expand out well when we talk about the
right to vote
you know blacks now have the right to
vote or women
have the right to vote but but it isn't
women as a group that go in to vote it's
it's a woman or it's a black person or
it's or if it's you know if it's right
violation of Rights it's a woman who
suffers are a black person who suffers
at the hands of oppressive pressors and
so it's the suffering of an individual
that is what we should care about
because groups can't suffer those are
just concepts a concept can't suffer but
an individual organism with a brain that
senses pain and records that that's what
where it's at
here at reason our tagline is free minds
and free markets and you draw a pretty
clear connection between the two when
you talk about the emergence of free
markets kind of at the same time as the
Scientific Revolution was occurring and
you identify a group of French
scientists who called themselves
physiocrats
could you just explain kind of the
simultaneous rise of scientific ideas
and you know lays a fair after the
Scientific Revolution particularly with
the synthesis of the physical sciences
from Galileo through Newton everybody
after that wanted to do something
similar in their areas biology medicine
law economics politics and so on Thomas
Hobbes for example self-consciously said
I am the Galileo of civil society by
which he meant not just I want to be
famous like these guys but that just
like Newton discovered there are certain
principles and laws that govern the
universe in the physical world and
Harvey show that there's certain
principles of the heart beating and the
circulatory system and so on
that operate in everybody and that these
are laws we can we can understand and
then apply and try to make the world a
better place
so Hobbes said that about the civil
society and so ever since Hobbes you
know all the Enlightenment thinkers all
the way through Locke and Jefferson and
Franklin and so on and these guys were
all scientists of a sort I mean they
didn't call themselves that the word
wasn't even used natural philosophers
they were looking for principles so the
physiocrats were saying hey maybe the
economy is like the human body you know
there's a flow a flow of capital like a
flow of blood and you know
a system to the world in economics and
we can understand it now they concluded
that it's best to not have too much
regulation in it because they little
flow more smoothly like blood through
the body without all these controls on
it and and so that that gave rise to the
whole free-market economic theory and
that turns out as I show to actually be
really good for expanding the moral
sphere if you want to break down the
xenophobic barriers between strangers
there's no sure way to do it then let
them trade and each make a profit from
each other because it doesn't matter
what color you are what gender you are
what sexual preference you are I only
care about your price and your quality
your product and from that we develop
trust and it turns out that that nations
that trade with each other are less
likely to have conflict that democracies
and free trade two of the biggest
factors predicting less violence between
states everything you're saying kind of
rests on the claim that morality is
universal and discoverable the critique
that you've brought you probably get
sometimes maybe call it a postmodern
critique is that there is no truth or at
least it's not discoverable and that
logic and reason are arbitrary cultural
rules I mean is there anything to that
is there are there limits to how far
rational debate and reason can actually
get us you ever Dawkins the expression
about [ __ ]
show me a postmodernist at 30,000 feet
in a in a jet and I'll show you the
hypocrite I mean even they who say
there's no such thing as reality there
is a reality and it better be working
right you know in a jet at 30,000 feet
well the same is true for morality you
show me a post - isn't a no such thing
is right and wrong and and then cheat
them out of their income tax or you know
or some deal that they got and they'll
immediately feel vengeful angry hurt you
know that there was an injustice they
want righted everybody feels that way
the primates feel that way its inborn we
care about what's fair we care about
being treated and those things I claim
are real they're discoverable in the
brains of social primates like us but do
you think there's really a possibility
reaching consensus about these things
that are all true the true universal
true things well probably not quite as
consensual as say F equals MA in physics
that's you know the the equations are
gonna be a lot more complex than that
but still in general there's I think
certain principles we can all agree on
it really is fairly basic and everybody
knows those principles they feel them
deeply inside the moment you you prick
somebody do I not bleed you know as
Shakespeare's [ __ ] you know I I hurt
too I feel vengeful too this is part of
human nature and everybody knows this I
think this postmodern thing this too
shall pass
and his whole nonsense I also debunk
this nonsense about the is a barrier
that you know the naturalistic fallacy
Hume never meant that Hume just said you
shouldn't extrapolate into moral values
without good reason you can't just say
this is the way it is therefore it ought
to be that way you gotta have good
reason so I claim well we do have good
reasons democracies are better than
autocracies free markets are better than
top-down tyrannical you know economic
systems communist systems and so on
there are certain things we know work
you can measure it just look at North
Korea versus South Korea on a nighttime
map you can see the difference or look
at the average height of North Koreans
versus South Koreans about three inches
difference these political economic
systems translate into real health
measures quality of life measures you
emphasize that empiricism is a process
you know the scientific method is a
process and the benefit of it is you
actually have to prove your way is
better than my way instead of just
pointing to some tradition the response
to that from you know a conservative
perspective or maybe even sometimes a
libertarian perspective is that you can
veer into what Hayek called scientism
where you're relying on so-called
experts who think they know more than
they actually do know and that's where
the role of tradition is tradition shows
you that this institution has worked and
survived over a long period of time how
do you avoid falling into the trap of
scientism or pseudo scientific traps
but even like Burke's notion that
tradition should matter because those
things that are built up over centuries
are tried-and-true but that's an
empirical argument that's saying look
our ancestors for the past century have
tried a lot of different things and
these things they came up with they they
learn from hard knocks experience so we
shouldn't just overthrow the regime on a
whim but but that's not a philosophical
argument that's saying we have data
showing that this works so before you
say it doesn't work you better have good
arguments counters even that's an
Enlightenment rational argument that's
an argument based on reason you can't
just say we're gonna overthrow the
government just cuz I feel like it you
better have good reasons for it and it
better be better than the last centuries
worth of data we have even a democracy
where you know we can't agree you think
one thing I think the other things so
we're gonna put it up for a vote but
even that's a kind of an experiment
Franklin called it and you know the and
Jefferson both referred to as the
American experiment that and their
argument was that no one knows how to
run a country
nobody can do it on their own so we have
to set it up where we tweak the
variables and run the experiment for a
couple years then tweak them again and
run it again and so even though you can
take like all 50 different states and
look at all their different tax systems
and say well which ones produce this and
that and the other you have data sets
that's a kind of empirical experiment
the title of the book the moral arc
comes from a 19th century abolitionist
preacher who said essentially that the
moral arc is a long one but it bends
towards justice where do you think
Parker's sense of optimism came from and
where does yours come from well Parker's
who inspired of course Martin Luther
King Jr's I think both of theirs was
more of wanting things to be a certain
way rather than seeing that that is the
way that they are because when he said
that on the eve of this American Civil
War when slavery was in full bloom in
the United States it didn't seem like it
was bending anywhere but bad but still I
think that's an optimism of we want to
make things better I think now we have
the data to show that it really has
gotten better I mean even when King said
it in 63 there had been some measurable
progress but I think most of it that
we've observed is
is happen in the last half century or so
as the data we've collected about the
past and the things that have happened
so rapidly it's just in the last half
century and and so I think if we
extrapolate that out there there is
reason for hope what are some of the
kind of greatest developments that you
see that in the data that gives you that
sense of optimism well I think for
example the number of electoral
democracies liberal democracies where
everyone has the franchise that was
essentially zero in 1900 women couldn't
vote in any major country until the
early 20th century for example and now
that figure is up to one hundred and
nineteen out of the hundred and ninety
countries so we're over half now and so
that's progress the the spread of civil
rights and civil liberties to almost
everybody pretty much everybody in the
Western world even gays same-sex
marriage and homosexuality we're in the
middle of that revolution right now and
it's a beautiful thing because you can
see how it unfolds you can see who
objects to it mostly conservative
religious people you can see their
arguments which are based on holy books
and so forth
and you can watch them tumble and change
their minds even Obama you know when he
ran no eight I think marriage between a
man and woman and then twelve I changed
mine why why did he change his mind why
have all these people changed their mind
because there's a sweeping tide of
cultural shift toward expanding that
moral sphere and there's no good
arguments really why a gay shouldn't be
allowed to marry I'm optimistic because
if if that can happen then even us
atheist secularists who are sort of the
last of the groups to to be prejudiced
against and then animals I think all
this is going to happen in our lifetime
and I predict that by say 2020 gay
marriage will be like the black and
white drinking fountains or interracial
marriages debates were in the 50s and
that today's conservatives are more
liberal than liberals were in the 50s
just to wrap up what are the biggest
obstacles that you see standing in the
way of that moral progress and how are
we going to circumvent around them I
think the biggest thing I'm concerned
about is is Islamic fundamentalism Isis
Taliban its religion theocracies
you know tradition that's grounded and
nothing rational you can't reason
somebody out of something they didn't
reason their way into in the first place
it's a pure tribal deep instinct based
in religion that's religions my biggest
concern fundamentalist conservative
religion
I mean liberal Christians that you know
Jews and so forth that have gone through
the Enlightenment but that's not a
concern it's the pre enlightenment or
non enlightenment religious communities
that are the most threatening Michael
Shermer thank you very much for joining
you look them for Reason TV I'm Zack
white smaller